hello and welcome to this episode of the
APG accelerator Series in this video you
will learn how to implement and use
property sets in
APG a property set is a custom
collection of key value pairs that store
data API proxy and share flows can
retrieve these data when they execute
these key value pairs are stored into a
properties file as shown on the
following
example if in this example the name of
the file is my props do properties and
it contains seven key value pairs as an
example fu is a key and bar is the value
for the fu
key typically you use property sets to
store non-expiring data that shouldn't
be hardcoded in your API proxy logic you
can access property set data anywhere in
a proxy where you can access flow
variables in the following example
example you can access the value of the
fu key using the flow variable property
set. my props do
Fu some other important things to know
about property sets first you can scope
a property set to an API proxy revision
or environment when you create the
property set you cannot scope a property
set to an APG
organization second property set files
are resource files of type property is
that you can manage through the APG UI
or the APG API last but not least
property set files support the same
syntax as Java properties
files as mentioned in this video you can
access property sets variables from the
policies where you can access flow
variables like JavaScript policy extract
variable policy a sign message policy
the following example based on the
resource extract of of a JavaScript
policy gets the value of the full
property from the property set named my
props let me show you how you can deploy
a basic example of a property set on
your APG organization let's
begin go to the Google Cloud platform
and APG samples git repo and enter the
property set
sample in order to run this sample you
need the following
an AP GX instance with access configured
for external traffic as a user you need
permissions to deploy your API proxy
this can be granted to you to the APG
org admin role or the API and developer
admin roles to deploy the sample you
also need the common line tools shown
here if you are using Google Cloud shell
these tools are already
installed we have included a Google
Cloud shelter tutorial that you can
simply click to quickly get
started now that you're in the cloud
shell environment you can follow along
with the stepbystep
instructions first make sure you're
logged in with the right account then
change to the directory for this
sample to deploy the sample first open
up the env. sh file and set the
configuration to ref your APG
organization environment and external
host
name next run the included script to
deploy the sample to your APG instance
this might take a minute to
complete when the script completes you
should see a message showing the API
proxy you URL now run the Cur command
and notice the values in the
output you should see a jisen payload
whose content has been set based on
values extracted from a property set two
custom ERS have also been set based on
the same property
set now that you have seen the API proxy
in action let's look at how it is
configured in
APG you can access the APG you y
directly from the Google Cloud console
look for the property set API proxy
select the proxy and go to the develop
tab you see two policies defined and two
resource files of type properties and
JavaScript the properties file named my
props contains keys that are used by the
JavaScript and assigned message policies
first
the JavaScript policy gets two values
from the property set and set these two
values as custom response headers x-b
and x-
note then an assigned message policy
uses flow variables to set a custom
payload based on the same property set
using different keys and
values the JavaScript and assigned
message policies are example on how to
use flow variable to get values of keys
defined in a property set when you're
done with the sample you can provide us
with your feedback and then you can use
the cleanup script to delete the
configuration that was deploy to your
APG
organization we hope you found this
sample useful and if you enjoyed the
video please hit the like button below
you can also subscribe to our channel to
see more videos in the APG accelerator
series if you have questions please post
them on the APG Community thanks for
watching